oh yeah at least you got [ __ ] going
up Steve
I never know what I had to suffered
through
wait until you hear what I had to go
through yeah I never got my dick sucked
[Music]
[ __ ] bastards man and welcome back to
another phenomenal [ __ ] episode of
the careful boys featuring our favorite
careful girl Colleen oh wow favorite it
was voted
yeah oh so you wouldn't vote for me I
didn't vote no that's right I voted
against you you didn't vote against you
and I ran a campaign
he made posters he fundraised the field
campaign yeah sell half his woofer all
right anyways um Colleen
would you like to share anything with
the classroom today yeah so we were
talking about uh our upbringing
and uh my upbringing was a little little
strict I had my brother and I were both
a part of a family that was a
taught a lot of work ethic but to an
extreme extent sometimes
so uh one morning you know we go
downstairs we have our breakfast and we
look at the fridge and there's a list of
chores you know maybe some typical ones
like wash the dishes take out the trash
walk the dog right well this particular
day we had a
we were escorted outside to our backyard
where my dad was doing landscaping and
he had like buckets like probably this
size like at least like 20 of them for
each of us of rocks
like these shaped Pawn rocks for
landscaping they were all dirty he's
like so you're he brought two stools sat
him down we're in the sun with all these
buckets he's like sorry guys I want you
to wash the dirt off these rocks and
then put them back in the ground
[Music]
okay so what they were the Rocks already
on the ground no they were in the
buckets so they were in the buckets
dirty rocks in these buckets but they
were were they originally in the the
same dirt you're about to put them back
in yeah
I I didn't see that part they were
already in the bucket stop asking
questions okay so yeah they're just used
rocks it's pretty handy they're already
in the bucket so here's the thing he
he's trying to like
what I assumed that my dad was trying to
do was that he was trying to make these
rocks clean so they were presentable for
the landscaping and it looked nice right
um my method would be just put the rocks
in the dirt already dirty and just spray
it off the hose oh okay yeah all right
all right but you make a lot of mud
everywhere maybe okay fine keep going
shut them up
so uh I don't know maybe it was like a
Mr Miyagi moment uh that's what it
sounds like or it could have been a
cobra Kai moment shut the [ __ ] up you're
just saying like there's a day of
different schools same same but
different yeah so
um
my brother is a smart one he just shut
up he didn't ask any questions he's like
I'm gonna get this done super fast and
then I'm gonna go outside and play with
my friends I was just like I don't get
it like we're putting the dirty rocks
back in the dirt like it doesn't make
any sense like just making a whole fuss
about it and so my brother finishes in
maybe an hour right [ __ ] and my dad he's
he took my brother's last bucket of
probably like 40 rocks and put it in
front of me
to teach me a lesson about like just not
complaining about what you have to do
yeah I was out there for like eight
hours the Stone's going down like crying
like washing these rocks putting them
back in the dirt
that's like child labor to a degree so
anyways that was part of my upbringing
your brother does the one bucket in an
hour he takes you eight hours listen I
was crying the majority of the time
I was crying and arguing the majority of
the time of having to do this how old
were both of you you and your brother I
don't know probably like
10 and 11 10 11. is he older he's a year
older he's a year older is it normal to
come downstairs and you just get a
random chore like that absolutely so
every day is random it's not like the
usual like vacuum oh yeah there is like
the usual like
clean the bathrooms take out the trash
wash the dish but it was always written
on the fridge yeah so like my brother
Lance would be like Lance you have to do
this clean your your jobs are this and
you can't do anything that you want to
do until this list is completed or there
is like um pick a recipe for the family
and cook the meal for everybody to teach
us how to cook wow oh that sounds
useless
this sounds like a basic question but um
I think from my perspective I think
these guys will relate especially me
if you complete your task of chores that
is written on there you can do whatever
you want
I mean not like whatever you want but
yeah if you want to go outside and play
with your friends go play video games
it's like that's your free time now
you've completed your chores and your
tasks so been down for that that would
have been such an easy Transaction what
was yours like yeah I just feel like
that's rational it's like you do this
you receive this and I feel like
transactionally yeah the structure to it
there's organization even if it's unfair
it's like uh there's a logic to it
what's yours like [ __ ] Wheel of
Fortune and everyone is
who knows where you're gonna get today I
feel like sometimes my parents look at
me like he's having too much fun make
them do something you know it's like
it's just like discipline when you've
they just felt like it was necessary or
let's say you do something you're always
walking on eggshells yeah you do
something and then you do it too fast
why'd you do too fast there's something
wrong with you do this too like you
didn't do it well enough you did it fast
it was never like a to B it was like if
a then maybe B C D E and F and then if
you hit F let me reconsider a to c you
know what I'm saying it's the way you
did it too right that was always my [ __ ]
because if I told my maid to do
something too quickly my parents were
piss about it I love the idea that what
you guys think that we went through
versus you
I'm just saying her we're sitting here
listening okay I thought we were on the
same team everyone grew up in America by
the way I said well I'll be a careful
girl Colleen as usual [ __ ] idiot
she's a guest you're a co-host can't we
just be on the same side I'm on your
side but like my god dude
ridiculous accusation this chick's just
trying to [ __ ] say yeah my dad made
me wash some rocks he was like that's
pretty tight
I would love to watch I would have loved
to watch The Rocks if only but I had to
[ __ ] get hit with sticks instead yeah
right
[Laughter]
Amazing by the way that happened to me
too my parents were like oh you're
hanging out at home too much yeah guess
what this is what happened to my parents
did this [ __ ] to me like your parents
are like you're hanging at home too much
go outside and play no my mom would take
off my pants and blow me because she's
just like you're bored oh we should I
should probably suck on your dick
the life like the life that you think I
had is [ __ ] amazing
oh yeah at least you got blow jobs going
up Steve
I never know what I had to suffered
through yeah
I never got my dick sucked yeah yeah
to this day to me I had to learn more
like getting my dick versus from my mom
was like versus my girlfriend like this
weird difference yeah give me a break
you got problems man guys I swear to God
like [ __ ] Bart tell me about oh yeah
did you get those Chinese Christmas
cookies I'm like are you just talking
about [ __ ] those little cookies in a
tin that everyone gets at the grocery
store everybody and Bart's like it's a
[ __ ] Asian thing I'm like the Danish
one exactly they're dangerous they're
not Chinese
you called them Chinese cookies you're
the one who calls them Chinese cookies
well I only know what the Chinese people
give the Danish ones away
the Danish ones it's an Asian thing the
balloon
exactly dude yeah it's the best I
[ __ ] love this room God damn it the
Asian cookies
no dude my parents they're like dude if
if you're bored if you ever say you're
bored in the house you're gonna go work
in the yard you're actually gonna go do
a bunch of [ __ ] Landscapes you guys
had a yard
oh God here we go
there's no way you have a yard because
you're dancing you could move around
I wish we had dirt and water hey I wish
I could have moved around but there's no
floor there's no floor
because you know how valuable floor is
yeah
did they ever take those rocks and
actually use them that's the worst part
of it they sat there for [ __ ] weeks
and they got dirty again no no purpose
oh other than to teach I honestly think
it was like my dad
either teaching us a lesson or just
completely trolling us I'm gonna get
these kids today but your dad is
subscribed so let's just see what was
the lesson you learned and he passed he
subscribed in the afterlife what was the
lesson that you learned just in case
oh is he not dead no he is oh he is
but did he click the Bell first
yeah as he was passing oh [ __ ] uh I was
I didn't even know what I asked anyone
have you ever like have you ever asked
him about that like later in life like
about that situation he's dead Nick
before before jeez man later in life but
not too later in life well you know I
think my dad was like a low-key troll
like I think he did things for his own
humor and then played it off like it was
some strategic and philosophical thing
that is pretty funny it is funnier
that's parents dude wait
did your mom really blow you uh well it
everyone was fighting for it right
what do you mean wait obviously all my
aunts and like everybody like they're
always trying to give me the best time
ever
everyone's fighting for it everyone's
fighting to blow you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't just my mom like it was
like my aunt's like my uncles
everybody's just trying to [ __ ] blow
me and like it would be a great time
because I'm white you know I'm white in
America so you just get blown every day
you wake up you get deep throat blowies
from all your siblings and all your
relatives and it's like so tight and
like you just [ __ ] all you can do is
like this basically you go like that and
you go like that
look at the video dude just turn it off
what else are we gonna talk about dude
when you know you know by the way the
back of your mole is better to be filed
off
I felt some [ __ ] in my life let's cut
let's confirm this with an unbiased
perspective Tyler
what's up and has your mom ever blown
you when you woke up hey look at us
hey
let's go let's see dude being white in
America is all about the Deep Throat
go in the middle between them between us
it's like oh hi Mama
how much tequila have you guys had how
much tequila have you guys
thank you Tyler appreciate it you're
welcome
[Music]